eu foreign ministers meeting earlier
this week in the four weeks since the
invasion they've already agreed four
packages of sanctions which were some of
the toughest ever imposed as well as a
fund of over a billion dollars to buy
weapons for ukraine i asked the eu's top
foreign affairs official about further
measures when the leaders meet here soon
do you expect there to be further
sanctions adopted this week and could
they be extended to the energy sector
formal adoption of sanctions require
procedure
and i don't think during this week it
will be
a formal adoption of sanctions according
with our procedures
the reason is this the european union is
now divided on even tougher measures
some countries notably germany oppose a
complete ban on russian oil and gas
experts estimate that before the war
russian gas was costing western
countries a billion dollars a day
germany has been very foolish over the
years i mean along with some other
member states not only didn't they
reduce their dependency on russian oil
and gas they actually built this huge
north stream ii pipeline despite the
fact that most of the other member
states said don't do it because russia
will weaponize it which is exactly what
russia has done
even if sanctions are tightened some
believe putin may not back down because
he's not accomplished any of his wars
aims so it's essential in russian
thinking that ukraine doesn't lean to
the west and i think that
putin will prevent
that at any price as long as it's as
long as it takes and at any cost that is
what we see happening right now and if
that means
a long-lasting war and i think we are in
it for a long time
i think russia will be prepared to take
that cost when european union and nato
leaders gather here in brussels you can
expect another show of unity more strong
words against vladimir putin but when it
comes to concrete action they've
probably gone as far as they can go
james bay's al jazeera brussels